so California it is a big big state and
there is a plan being floated by Timothy
Draper who is a venture capitalist and
he's invested in a ton of things like
Twitter hotmail Skype and Tesla and he
wants to split California into six
different states that's right let's look
at the states he's proposed Jefferson
would include the northernmost portion
South California would be comprised of
San Diego and Eastern LA while the rest
of LA would be called West California
North Kerala fornia would be built
around Sacramento Central California
would be made up of the Central Valley
Farm region Silicon Valley would include
San Francisco and Silicon Valley would
become the nation's richest state just
by dividing it up just like that they'd
probably like that so I think this is
kind of interesting because we have a
huge country in the first place you know
I mean we got a lot of states a lot of
people with different interests and
California's huge California could be a
country many times over and its
economies big enough for that but do
these ideas are they just like pie in
the sky kind of like never happening
right completely pie in the sky but
what's great is I'm sure he's heavily
invested in Silicon Valley and it's
another great four-door where he gets to
be all by himself in his like rich State
best thing in all these tech startups
and he's like I want them to split up
into their own state so then I can
control the tax I've advocated this for
a long time I I think that we should not
only split up California we split up the
country go back to the Civil War and let
them win you guys win you guys get to
leave all you guys you guys get to leave
it they're gonna let them take over they
don't know they think you just want them
to let them take it to separate so then
we get to see what two countries would
really be they get to have their
Republican utopia we get to have a
regular country yeah so they get to have
a country where you know there's
unregulated oil drilling and guns on
everybody's hip and religion in every
classroom and slaves and we and we get
to have you know science healthcare and
all the other Glenn in a clean
environment so I'll take that and by the
way I am actually am for breaking up
California not no no joke because we are
unrepresented we're underrepresented
in the Congress right we only have two
senators for California you go to
Wyoming which has a state with the
population less than my [ __ ]
neighborhood they also get two senators
right so they are over-represented and
that's what's wrong with the that's a
big problem what's wrong with
legislation in America the people the
minority viewpoint which is the
Republican people way over-represented
in the Senate way over-represented just
like and also in the Congress Democrats
got a million more votes and Republicans
that yet they their way minority in the
Congress so District Jimmy every time
you lose an election you just
redistricting it but so the Senate thing
I think is kinda interesting cuz
everyone gets to and that's part of
that's a constitution but you know
there's supposedly the House of
Representatives then mitigates that
because it is by population but you're
saying that's not even that's not
happening it's just not good no no no I
mean if you look at the Senate I mean we
need the Senate to come along with and
so the people who represent no one get
to have way more power than they ever
should so it's not one person one vote
it's they get way more than one person
one vote in Wyoming or Montana or South
Dakota any of those Paul's states with
small populous is and they're all
conservative they're all run by
corporations they get way more voice in
our government which is why we have the
situation we have Americans ninety
percent want to get gun regulation we
all want a single-payer health care we
all want to get out of Afghanistan and
wreck that none of that's happening
because a bunch of guys in Wyoming don't
want it to happen that's a direct shot
of Cheney family if I'm telling you it
sounds funny but it's the truth yeah
is this one of these things where not
only is the country like if you look at
the map of the country where we're blue
you know we're blue around water
basically and then there were red in the
middle that's where you're blue wherever
you don't want to live that's the shitty
red state park yeah it's kind of true
don't show me a place that's red you
want to live there's no [ __ ] place
that I want to live in a city you
liberal elitist yeah that's what they're
saying even in Texas Houston goes
Democrat any Austin goes endemic so you
go to the cities which is where human
beings are supposed to [ __ ] live yeah
you start to think normally you have
universe
you start to progress you have a
progressive thought right isn't that
funny than during the elections when
they're always like oh he's from the
city he's a liberal yes he went to
college he Bubba you know what I mean as
opposed to what what do you want do you
want some I want a man of the people who
his hands ring the dirt yes yes yeah I
remember I was watching Matt Lauer on
today's show and he was talking about
how people like why is it people from
rural place but from real America but
he's doing his show in New York City I
guess you can't find a regular Joe
anywhere huh in New York City where's
all the regular people